[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france24 la
corte interamericana de derechos humanos
condenó a ecuador por el caso de paola
guzmán albarracín una adolescente que
sufrió violencia sexual durante dos años
en un colegio público y que tras quedar
embarazada se decidió acabar con su vida
sus agresores en la institución no
hicieron nada para salvarla y el estado
debe asumir la responsabilidad de su
muerte es un fallo histórico porque
establece por primera vez estándares
para prevenir que las niñas y las
adolescentes sufran violencias sexuales
en los entornos educativos de toda
américa latina y el caribe la justicia
llegó a 18 años después pero trabajo por
fin reparación para pettitte a
albarracín madre de paola
a continuación y con mucho respeto les
presentamos un resumen de este caso tan
doloroso pettitte albarrasín madre de
paola del rosario guzmán albarracín por
fin ha visto la justicia por el crimen
contra su hija en 2002 paola se suicidó
a los 16 años tras ser repetidamente
violada por el vicerrector de su colegio
tras años de impunidad la corte
interamericana de derechos humanos
condenó al estado ecuatoriano por la
violación de la que fue víctima a su
hija en un centro educativo estatal de
guayaquil ella era un presente que ya
entonces para todas las niñas de todos
los colegios de otros países que ya no
debemos permitir estos abusos toda la
fue causada y abusada sexualmente por el
vicerrector del colegio bolívar spine
surita un hombre de 64 años que prometió
ayudarle con sus estudios y mejorar sus
calificaciones a cambio de relaciones
sexuales ella tenía entonces 14 años y
el abuso continuó durante dos años más
cuando quedó embarazada el agresor
intentó que paola se practicara un
aborto con la asistencia del médico del
plantel quien ofreció a la menor
realizarla el procedimiento a cambio de
relaciones sexuales todas estas
agresiones le provocaron una depresión
que terminó en un suicidio mediante la
ingesta de
blanco poco antes de arribar al colegio
el 12 de septiembre de 2002 el proceso
penal que buscó esclarecer los hechos se
suspendió tras la fuga del vicerrector y
el 18 de septiembre de 2008 la justicia
ecuatoriana declaró prescrita la acción
penal y aunque se intentó realizar una
mediación con el estado no hubo
resultados la directora ejecutiva del
centro ecuatoriano para la promoción y
acción de la mujer
lita martínez quien llevó al caso hasta
la corte interamericana de derechos
explica que el fallo determinó que la
agresión ejercida contra la menor afectó
a su derecho a una vida libre de
violencias le provocó graves
sufrimientos y tuvo relación con su
decisión de quitarse la vida le obliga
que pida disculpas públicas como un
reconocimiento internacional de que el
estado ecuatoriano violento los derechos
humanos de paola y de sus familiares
la corte acusó a ecuador de ser
responsable por la violencia sexual
ejercida en contra de paula que fue
tolerada por las autoridades estatales y
obligó al estado a adoptar entre otras
medidas de protección y sancionar a los
agresores dentro de los colegios vamos a
hablar del tema y para eso nos acompaña
la mamá de paola la señora petita
albarracín y también está con nosotros
catalina martínez quien es
la directora regional del centro de
derechos reproductivos un saludo para
ustedes dos gracias por estar con
nosotros y señora petita paso a
preguntarle qué sucedió o qué va a
suceder con el vicerrector del colegio
con el médico del colegio y con todos
los presuntos cómplices de estos abusos
y de estas violaciones que sufrió su
hija
bueno hasta la fecha de hoy yo no tengo
conocimiento nada porque nunca hicieron
nada por cogerlo preso ni a él ni al pro
ni al doctor ni a los cómplices y
encubridores especialmente el rector del
colegio lamentablemente mi país no
hicieron nada para que esto se haga
justicia
ellos están libre y feliz mientras que
mi hija se murió y yo estoy sufriendo
por esta por esta por esta muerte tantos
años y desde de lucha y sacrificio para
ello es la libertad con este con este
hombre no han hecho nada las autoridades
de aquí de mi país
catalina esto sucedió en el colegio
bolívar espn sur y está usted sabe qué
cambios ha podido aplicar hasta el
momento en la institución para proteger
a las niñas o han sido 18 años no
solamente de impunidad sino en los que
esta institución no ha tomado el ejemplo
de lo que sucedió
han sido 18 años en donde efectivamente
podemos ver que el estado de ecuador ha
tomado algunas medidas para avanzar en
la protección atención y prevención de
la violencia sexual pero no ha sido
suficiente entonces precisamente esta
sentencia de la corte interamericana
derechos humanos es tan importante
porque la corte como responsabiliza al
estado precisamente no haber prevenido
este tipo de violencia le ordena al
estado de ecuador que permite toda su
institucionalidad educativa de
herramientas para que este tipo de
violencia pueda ser atendida prevenida y
bueno y sobre todo para educar tanto
alumnas alumnos profesores y profesoras
frente a los temas más relevantes de la
violencia sexual y de la educación
sexual y reproductiva eso es la parte
institucional pero señora petita también
está la parte humana la parte familiar y
es lo que le tocó usted directamente y
algo que seguramente
no va a cambiar en toda su vida pero si
puede cambiar para otros padres qué es
lo que usted les diría a los padres de
familia a las niñas que están expuestas
a violencia sexual no solamente en su
país sino en américa latina'
claro en todas partes del mundo yo lo
único que le puedo aconsejar que
conversé con su niña que le dé confianza
que no la dejen sola que averigüen iu a
las niñas que no se dejen manipular que
ellas confíen en su madre les cuente
todo lo que les vaya a pasar en el
colegio eso de amenazas éste mató a tu
madre para que no digan nadie mató a tus
hermanas eso es mentira eso es
manipulación para que un efecto para que
las niñas se queden calladas y no hablen
con los padres
esto es un tema que va a tomar mucho
tiempo son 18 años solamente para llegar
a la conclusión que dio con su sentencia
la corte y dh catalina pero háblenos un
poco más acerca de estos cambios que
usted nos mencionaba que tienen que
ocurrir dentro del ecuador para proteger
a las niñas esto nunca debió suceder en
primera instancia ecuador
no la protegió cuando hubo oportunidad
de hacer prevención no la protegió
después durante 18 años en los que hubo
litigios y negociaciones que se fueron
infructuosas pues ahora qué es lo que
tiene que hacer el estado
y si efectivamente digamos que es muy
importante primero establecer que la
corte
tiene tres conclusiones principales no
la primera de ellas es que aquí no se
previno ni se atendió la violencia
sexual entonces que el estado tiene que
adoptar medidas y ahorita voy a voy a
precisar cuáles serían lo segundo es que
en este caso la corte también dice que
la educación sexual y reproductiva es
absolutamente necesaria para que las
niñas niños y adolescentes puedan
entender cómo funcionan las relaciones
afectivas y sexuales y también
identificar los abusos no y un tercero
una tercera grande conclusiones acerca
de la necesidad de erradicar
estereotipos no porque precisamente
porque a paola la encasillaron en el
estereotipo de la adolescente
provocadora es que se creó este
imaginario y que ya no merecía
protección entonces teniendo en cuenta
que estos son tres grandes conclusiones
la corte le dice al estado que tiene que
es específicamente tomar medidas para
primero tener información estadística
actualizada sobre las situaciones de
violencia sexual contra niñas
adolescentes en el ámbito educativo
tomar medidas para la detección de casos
de violencia sexual contra niñas y niños
en el ámbito y para promover su denuncia
tercero establecer capacitaciones a
personal del ámbito educativo respecto
al abordaje y prevención precisamente
estas situaciones de violencia sexual y
finalmente el estado tiene que adoptar
políticas públicas para la provisión de
orientación asistencia y atención a las
víctimas de estas de esta violencia en
el ámbito educativo y a sus familias y
para hacerle la última pregunta catalina
comencé a hablándole a la señora petita
de estos agresores directos de paola los
primeros responsables podremos ver en un
futuro próximo que ecuador tome cartas
en el asunto porque esto no solamente
lamentablemente le pasó a paola sino que
en general los autores de crímenes de
violencia contra la mujer en la mayoría
de oportunidades salen impunes no pagan
castigo no pagan pena muchas veces
porque prescriben los casos como sucedió
con ustedes hace algunos años
o porque el estado no se esfuerza por
que las pruebas sean puestas ante la ley
de acuerdo bueno yo quiero rescatar
primero un tema frente a la justicia
internacional y es que esta es una
justicia de una naturaleza diferente en
el sentido en el que aquí finalmente
quien resulta responsable de toda esta
vulneración de derechos humanos no es un
individuo no es la persona que
efectivamente ejerció la violencia en
este caso sino el estado como un todo
que no hizo nada para que este tipo de
violencia no existieran antes primero el
agresor fue un funcionario público o
segundo fue en una institución educativa
pública en donde se toleró y perpetua
este tipo de violencia y tercero pues el
aparato judicial no funcionó en ninguna
etapa del proceso entonces acá si
tenemos justicia porque es un estado que
está respondiendo por todos estos hechos
y tiene que responder de una manera muy
estructural no primero tomando medidas
de política pública que cambien
estructuralmente la situación y que nos
permitan que estos hechos no vuelvan a
repetirse y segundo precisamente con una
reparación integral no sólo para doña
petita sino también con medidas
simbólicas que permitan explicarle a la
sociedad qué fue lo que pasó en este
caso porque es inaceptable y qué medidas
el estado está tomando ahora
específicamente frente a los
responsables de estos hechos si bien
esto no es algo que la corte ordena
específicamente pues nosotras y
esperamos que en el proceso de
implementación de esta decisión el
estado nos haga una propuesta frente a
cómo va a reaccionar desde el ámbito de
la justicia así sea efectivamente hacer
un informe público en donde se
esclarezca qué fue lo que pasó aquí y se
honre la memoria de paula si justamente
señora petita han sido 18 años de lucha
de defender la honra de su hija porque
también se dijeron conceptos equivocados
sobre lo que realmente pasó con ella y
por eso este último tramo del programa
quisiera ofrecérselo para que usted nos
hable de quién en realidad fue su hija
quien era paola porque este es el
momento para honrar
carla y para recordarla con todo el
cariño que se merece y con todo el
cariño que se merece usted hoy que
aunque sea amargo hay una celebración
porque usted recibe justicia claro bueno
yo no me podía quedar callada yo tenía
que luchar y hablar por mi hija porque
yo conocí a mi hija yo conocí a mi hija
porque ella es una niña tranquila alegre
en su hogar pero todo esté toda la
familia no le faltó en el amor el cariño
y lo que le pasó le pasó en el colegio
en todo el colegio le pasó yo nunca
llegué a saber nada yo construye un
colegio femenino yo confíe que mi hija
la iban a cuidar que la iban a dar todo
el respeto todo y el amor pero no fue el
contrario que encontró un monstruo pero
mi hija era una niña tranquila y era una
niña feliz
en el hogar humilde aunque sea pero no
le falta el amor el cariño de toda la
familia
señora petita gracias a usted catalina
gracias también por sus explicaciones
sobre todas las implicaciones de este
caso muchísimo respeto para ustedes
mucho agradecimiento por tomarse el
espacio para hablar de estos temas tan
difíciles y tan personales y seguimos en
france 24 quédense con nosotros
[Música]